bro
how you just got that in the tuck like
that come
on there's no way to have a secret
ingredient yeah that's the secret
ingredient bro that's why all these guys
egg yolks this is just come on drink
your egg yolk come on
it's not 10 coconut water bro can I just
ask you 10 Logan no water that's what
I'm saying
I I think that there is a propaganda
campaign against you guys I think the
competition
is
sowing seeds of doubt in your brand
oh you're talking about you're talking
about lobbyists I think that they're
people that are lobbying against you and
they are trying to push narratives
Schultz
I had to go on multiple news outlets and
say hey
our caffeine levels are comparable to
all our competitors even lower than our
competitors we are a better for you
beverage I had to basically be like yeah
we are fdaa approved no FDA investors go
investigations taking place Chuck
Schumer urged for it to take place like
well I can't even I I can't even get
into it but it's lobbyists it's lobbyist
that we don't have lobbyists for whom
that I can't say brother we know what it
is
a question here's the question are they
worried that you guys are gonna get big
enough where they have to they have to
buy you are you going to achieve escape
velocity
I don't know if I'm allowed to say so
I'm just gonna just so one of the
companies cannot buy you it would be
considered a monopoly oh
both not buy you only one of the two oh
as far as I know the one is not able to
buy us ah okay so they're still we got
it we got bro we're taking market share
like not not me trying to flex that
we're eating [__] market share and
taking dollars out of these massive
corporate conglomerates Pockets so for
everybody's watching what usually
happens in a situation like this is a
giant billion dollar Corporation sees
some competition coming up this happens
in Tech it happens in retail it happens
and everything and they go hey this is
about to reach escape velocity well
there'll be a competitor we have to buy
them before that happens right is that a
pretty fair way to describe the scenario
or shut them down before it happens you
know try to create enough cheaper to
shut them down
wait then it is to have to buy them
later because bro we're like we're
Innovative we're edgy we're bold but
also let's just back up for a second the
fact that
they're coming at you for a beverage
being like unhealthy or whatever it is
like I know that Coca-Cola doesn't want
people looking into Coca-Cola
don't get me started that's what started
on the sugar content but that's what
made me start looking at and go wait a
minute is this the let's destroy the
brand campaign before we have to buy it
what are we doing what are we doing wait
the only thing I'm confused why do you
think they want to shut you down I think
they just want to drive down the price
so then they can buy you at a cheaper
well if it gets solo they don't have to
buy it at all because people will just
buy their stuff they want to not buy it
because buying it is going to cost a
billion what's cheaper acquisition or
the campaign but right now they're at a
place where I don't think
they can be destroyed like products
everywhere no no Prime yeah I feel it's
everywhere you know popular it's like
how can you destroy that and show like
things go you know okay okay
but it might it might it might be tough
we just we we're doing a couple things
right and one of which is we're speaking
directly to an audience that uh
appreciates our product likes the
product it's a it's a good better for
you products than our competitors like
all of them yeah and Casey neistat gave
you the shout out
and he was like listen I'll be honest
dog the energy the energy I mean I love
the hydration but the energy I drink it
before every workout I don't have any
crash and I'm in the best [__] shape
of my life it's like my pre-workout
essentially okay so here's the thing
that that I'm trying to understand where
do you get the money to sponsor the
soccer teams and the athletes
like that net Prof fit bruh is it profit
or is it investors going against net
profit we have no investors we have zero
investors Prime has six owners
two of them are managers me and JJ's
managers
four main ones are under the age of 30.
whoa team of wizards
sorry not me the team that we are
partnered with
the [__] Wizards they're really good
I thought you had some Saudi money and
they were paying all the soccer teams
you guys are paying the soccer teams and
the athlete can we announce the Holland
yeah yeah that's that's why I asked him
to come out we're announcing it tomorrow
yeah okay Airline Holland yeah is the
latest sponsored athlete which is
unbelievable we've been working on that
for eight months for America I don't
[__] believe I don't think that we
understand what it is he's the guy right
it's like I was told there's a chance
that like him and mbappe could be like
the Ronaldo and Messi of this generation
oh wow which is like and I I caught it'd
be like catching LeBron James in 2006
yeah we got him on a podcast we got our
all our assets we made it yeah it's it's
insane it's insane I don't even it's
hard to comprehend it's a brand he's so
fun yeah he's awesome dude he's he's a
great way why was it eight months to
make that happen uh we had a hard time
catching him in his location because he
trains all year round and just deal
points the kids is hot dude he's got
deals on the table
did you have to uh beat out the
competition was there another offer we
have to beat out a lot a lot of
competition for these like even to get
the UFC bid
um uh Arsenal some of the new teams were
signing yeah yeah can you we'll bleep it
out okay how much does it cost to
sponsor a soccer team
it it changes on each one you have to
bleep it out if I say it believe it
Arsenal was
wow the ROI is great on that of course
here's what we do bro maximize profits
and cut costs what is the cost cut oh
you don't have to pay for ads you guys
are the ads it's the [__] Tesla Model
yeah Elon never put an advertisement on
TV once he is the marketing I don't so
your whole marketing budget is you guys
and nobody can influence better than you
guys can so you saved the hundreds of
millions oh my God yeah yeah oh that's
[__] genius whoever owns Gatorade we
don't know who they are so they can't be
out there they're not wrestling they're
not on podcast they're not boxing
they're not creating news like as
annoying as this whole thing with Dylan
is they're still Prime attached to every
aspect of it yeah
oh wow yeah
how do you apply that to TV film what's
the other team what's the wizard like
got it
our partners yeah I I I don't want to
say too much they prefer to be anonymous
but like but like it's it's a business
um it's a business
technique and I think I'd push for
everyone who wants to get into it to do
is like make sure you have good partners
you know I've gotten screwed over a lot
like a lot a lot and I got really really
lucky with a good team on this one even
JJ KSI is a [__] Superstar dude like
he works so hard he's down for the cause
like it's all good bro I it's dude it's
too much prime talk bro okay we're
trying to talk no but for me it's not
about the beverage like I don't care how
much [__] calories and [__] is in it
but I do I'm interested in the math and
I'm interested in the finance of it
because I thought that you had investors
and I thought the whole plan was we are
going to
uh oil money sports drinks in the same
way that they've oil moneyed soccer
players but the fact that it's coming
just from you guys is very interesting
if I tell you how much we've made
internally this year yes year to date
yes will you bleep it yes
believe it yeah
[Laughter]
that is gross profit yeah so you have to
pay your expenses you have to pay your
so
oh now I kind of understand why you
always got the bottle I I know you
understand the pressure now I remember
thinking and I remember almost texting
you like bro is it annoying to always
carry the [__] bottle but that number
makes it crazy and this is the pressure
to your forehead yeah yeah I was
thinking about getting a prime tattoo
under my eyes